welcome to this video stolen candy 13
now this is a new handle right yeah at
least one that I never played it's not
totally new get players all the time
that you never have faced before really
am pretty big player pool iam so
probably you're ready opening yep yeah
it's grabbing the pawn and that's not a
bad line at least if you know what
you're doing trying to get the pawn back
and this is a really funny line 24 it
seems that he knows irnos a little bit
about this okay so he does not which is
not not a problem of course let's see i
can take c4 on you for you I guess you
form yeah mayne clearly it weakens the
the central structure but the time is
also valuable
not be should be six what other move is
there okay sometimes a bit a bit in bit
curious when when time is spent you
think isn't this the only move so let's
see an interesting decision now how do i
set up my central formation they can go
be three bishop be tuned this kind of
thing or d3 Bishop e3 which is
interesting looking at the the weekend
squares on the queenside there should be
six is in fact threatening to win a pawn
so he has to do something about it yeah
yeah I can go deform everything else
hailing I can do this just grab some
central space okay that's maybe not a
bad decision just taking this end saying
okay I'm solid what is your your plan
like e6 and just put it on light squares
now why not
and white can always claim a little
something with the two bishops but it's
nothing nothing super great you six
would be nice if black my probably does
not manage that by getting a night to be
form yeah it's not set clear how good
the night is there okay an interesting
question is what about d5 is d5 a move
that I'm threatening maybe I am now d5
probably I will play it if he allows
that it's not so hard to prevent it's
not so it's not so easy to prevent d 5
would open up the D file I mean his
setup has cost some time am Bishop e6
Bishop d5 back to his six then he took
on c form and so on this is all took
time yeah come on I'm not going to make
a big fuss out of this just going to
push this it I think it should be at
least a decent move and probably it is
just good right yeah when all my pieces
are sort of i wanted to draw an arrow
here it not in the game yeah the bishop
on g2 and the bishop one III and the
rock on the one i did suppose the Queen
this looks really nice yeah that looks
really nice actually what does his move
now I mean he can not even take on d5 I
think Queen d5 just winning directly and
e5 i have d 6 and this is terrible rook
c8 Queen B 5 mm it's not helping very
much now this was a really problematic
position what should he do well did we
see that this is really bad for him so
he M he needs his yet from I don't know
what but he needed to do something else
yeah brooke checks or the bishop takes
it's both good right but let's not spend
an hour be sure before I thought with a
day of f4 yeah okay come on rook e8 f4
he can then do some Desperados sacrifice
of the Queen with Knight f3 but it
really shouldn't be sufficient I can
just take here or not wait oh hmm that's
a bit embarrassing should be of 6 45
Bishop b5 rook t5 Bishop f6 rook takes
d5 takes bishop f6 it's not not totally
convincing or am i overlooking something
really simple here like I tend to do a
rookie 5 is not working f4 is also not
working okay i have to take so let's go
from them Bishop f6 route 65 I can just
take g7 and well sometimes it's really
idiotic what I'm doing can just take
here in a B takes on f6 Bishop d7 is
what I initially saw but this is not not
as convincing yeah I just have two
bishops for 4i rook and I'm winning the
Queen side with the pressure on
yeah okay I can take a five let's do it
let's just do that go back to c3 g6 I
have a six amongst other things Bishop
d5 is also not a bad move but a success
good look and they look on on b3 is
really not doing that much yeah bishop
device is enough
checkmate yeah I mean it didn't really
matter that was I was just too bad i was
really surprised how quickly this went
downhill I thought I was just having a
slight advantage but then it all of a
sudden got totally totally serious look
everyone looks normal Jim the computer
is already on 0.84 white yeah and it's
always with defic and I'm opening up the
position so quickly yeah well he lost
lots of China if we just think about the
bishop one to move three moves and then
here we are the fourth move them coming
yeah maybe this was a bit too much yeah
well computer actually wants to go look
be one instead of g5 but what exactly is
ok I see I see stop which is giving
giving not this but but this has some
sort of a defense but it's ok one he's
giving this as 0.6 but this is this is
really really terrible phobia
this-this-this bonza I just weak i can
go route beef I for example maybe I mean
with perfect play black candle with this
but it's not good not fun ok on this
this is what he did and to him yeah
oh I really didn't appreciate neither
three it's pasta then why does this is
better with the the better pieces but
okay that means that Bishop before was
still not the best probably root key one
and here we get exactly the the game
position where widest just winning up to
bishops against rogue and where this
stuff is just so we can always just
activating okay well thanks for watching